you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a world first
scheme offsetting greenhouse gas
emissions
by reducing the amount of methane cows
produce
[Applause]
it's been confirmed china's president
will attend a climate change summit with
french and german leaders tomorrow
as john kerry continues his visit to
shanghai
[Music]
and using the power of our oceans to
generate
clean energy
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
well coming up we'll be looking at
whether a diplomatic storm is brewing in
u.s china relations after it's confirmed
the chinese president will attend a
climate summit hosted by the french
tomorrow
and how matchbox is bringing its toy
cars
up to date with an eco-friendly makeover
but first the world's first carbon
credits for reducing emissions from
cows have been launched carbon credits
or offsetting is the practice of
reducing
co2 or other greenhouse gas emissions
made in one area
to compensate for emissions elsewhere
this could be by planting trees when you
take a flight for example
or now through paying for a new cattle
food
supplement because cows play a big part
in climate change
between 2000 and 2017 agriculture
accounted for roughly
two-thirds of all methane emissions
related to human activities with the
beef and dairy cattle industry
a big contributor in 2017 the earth's
atmosphere absorbed nearly 600 million
tons of methane the gas is 28 times more
powerful than co2
at trapping heat over a 100 year span
now muestral the company behind the new
food supplement claims
that if all cattle in the world edit
which is about one and a half
billion cows the methane reduction would
be equivalent
to taking 330 million cars
off the road sky's done whitehead
reports
and we promise he won't milk the cow
puns
[Applause]
chewing the card in the cotswolds but
these cows
or more specifically the methane they
emit
is a big problem when it comes to global
warming
the solution could lie a hundred miles
away in a laboratory
in the welsh valleys so this is our
research and development lab this is
where neutral is made mutral a british
swiss firm
is developing its latest version of a
food supplement for cows
which it claims can reduce the amount of
methane cattle produce
by 30 percent it is a game changer um
the cows are a huge
huge problem they are they put an
enormous amount of
of methane into the atmosphere and what
people don't appreciate is that methane
is so much more
powerful than carbon dioxide even as a
as a as a global warming gas
this chamber has no oxygen inside and
it's replicating
a cow's gut what dan is doing is seeing
just
how effective this new feed is at
removing the microorganisms
which create methane inside a cow
mutral hopes companies with big carbon
footprints will offset
their emissions by buying this food for
cattle
it's just one initiative to tackle
growing methane emissions
come on come on come on william mann's
organic cattle
are fed just grass and hay he's
concerned about the cost of such animal
food supplements but is open to the idea
it would need to be a supplement
alongside the grass
and if if if if they can come up with
with an organic and pasture fed
certified one in time
i would be very keen cows do
improve soil quality which helps lock
carbon in the ground but changing their
diet could help them do
more to reduce methane and in turn
global warming dan whitehead sky news in
aberdeleri
wales and there's more on the climate
impact of what you eat on the weekly
climate show
it's available from friday afternoons on
sky news social media channels our app
and our website now let's take a look at
some of the day's other climate news and
google earth has released a new time
lapse feature
allowing people to explore how our
planet is changing
it uses 24 million satellite photos from
the past 37 years
to show how everything from coastlines
to cities
forests and glaciers have transformed
over time
[Applause]
a 100 million dollar project to pinpoint
from space
large emissions of greenhouse gases from
individual sources like power plants and
oil refineries
has been announced the partnership which
includes the state of california and
nasa
will launch its first two satellites in
2023
the technology could increase pressure
on polluting industries to find
and plug leaks of gases such as methane
scientists are warning only three
percent of the world's land is
ecologically
intact an intact ecosystem has healthy
populations of its original animals
and undisturbed habitat reintroducing
some species like elephants or wolves to
damaged areas
could restore up to 20 percent of land
[Applause]
two large sections of cliff on the
jurassic coast in dorset
have collapsed the biggest rockfall seen
there in 60 years
a section of the beach remains cornered
off after massive chunks of rock
some the size of cars fell onto the sand
below
it's thought the recent mixture of warm
and cold weather caused parts of the
cliff to crack
and erode and two-thirds of people in
britain say they couldn't forgive a
friend for dropping
litter new research suggests people want
to live more sustainably after a year in
lockdown
and are even willing to fall out with
friends over it
now we've been speaking about the
importance of u.s climate envoy john
kerry's trip to china over the past
couple of days but
it could be overshadowed by an
announcement that the chinese president
xi jinping
will attend a climate change summit
tomorrow
with leaders from france and germany now
the virtual meeting will take place as
john kerry
is still in shanghai for talks with his
chinese counterpart
about climate change issues and this all
comes ahead of a big
summit the u.s president joe biden is
hosting on earth day
next week so let's speak to our climate
correspondent lisa holland
and lisa what do you make of this move
by the chinese president
well confirmation that xi jinping will
attend this
virtual conference hosted by the french
on friday
sends a clear message that the americans
are not the only ones trying to drive
climate ambition i think there is real
rival
between china and the united states over
this role of who is the global leader
on the one hand it is slightly awkward
but because of course uh america's
climate envoy john kerry
uh is in china at the moment having
talks with his
counterpart we're not hearing very much
about that
i think there is a real awareness that
the chinese don't want to be seen to be
being lectured to
by john kerry at the same time you could
say well look
there needs to be real change and real
ambition
so it's all shoulders to the wheel um
however
the most important thing is that it does
come ahead of this
crucial uh other virtual summit which
will be hosted by the americans next
week
and there does need to be real change
and real commitment from all sides these
nations that are the world's worst
polluters
and so we will hope that there will be
promises from not just the french the
chinese but also the americans
that will make a difference lisa thank
you
now i'm going to take you over to our
data dashboard now for a quick look at
the real-time
power mix which is up here at the very
top and you can see that today
we've got 51 coming from fossil fuels
we've got around 30 coming from
renewable sources and meanwhile
19 there from nuclear and that's because
average temperatures remain around one
degree below
seasonal average which is increasing
national electricity demand
at the same time wind output has been
relatively low over the last couple of
days
but solar output is relatively strong
it's currently the highest contributing
power source
behind gas and as of midday southwest
england has the lowest electricity
carbon intensity that's the measure of
co2 emissions per unit of electricity
used
with well over half its power coming
from solar
now the latest in our series of climate
diaries features a survivor of the
chernobyl
nuclear disaster inna bravaman has
developed a low-cost technology that
uses the power of the ocean waves
and converts it into clean energy
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is ina braverman and i'm
the founder and ceo of eco-wave power
i believe that wave power which can
produce
twice the amount of electricity that the
world produces now
is definitely a great cause
so how does the ecowa power technology
work our floaters are going up and down
with the movement of the waves
and they're pushing a hydro cylinder
which transmits biodegradable fluid
into land located accumulators in the
accumulators a pressure is being built
the higher the weights the higher the
pressure this pressure is used to turn
the hydro motor which is turning the
generator
we decided to install onshore and near
shore
on existent man-made structures such as
piers
breakwaters jetties and other types of
marine structures
when the waves are too high for the
system to handle the floaters
automatically rise
above the water level and they stay in
the upward position
until the storm passes although my real
passion
is wave energy i truly believe that the
solution for climate change and for the
world's problem
is integrating all renewable energy
sources
we need to use solar and wind and wave
and any type of renewable energy
technology in order to have a 100
renewable energy friendly world
now how do you fancy getting your hands
on a brand new tesla
roadster average cost 150 000
pounds for less than 20 quid well you
can
in miniature matchbox is releasing a
version of the electric vehicle and says
all its toys and packaging
will use recyclable materials by 2030.
matthew tompkin a matchbox car collector
since he was a child thinks making
electric cars as toys
is a big step forward and i think it's
so important now that
with the world being as it is and
climate change and stuff being
so important that actually um
it is important that the kids start to
see these type of cars and that they are
normal to them rather than
sort of extra one of the things i'm
trying to instill in in the boys
especially ronnie's seven
is about um how we cycle get rid of
plastic waste
um and all that stuff and he really
understands what an electric car is
um and uh yeah it's between a
lamborghini and a tesla roadster
and uh he's preferring the tesla rose so
i'm happy about that
and that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show we'll be speaking to
the director of the netflix hit my
octopus teacher
about saving the kelp forest off the
coast of south africa
where it was filmed that's on tomorrow's
daily climate show see you then